so we have some tables here that give us
what the function f what the functions f
and g are when you give it certain
inputs so when you input negative 4 f of
negative 4 is 29 that's going to be the
output of that function and so we have
that for both f and g and what i want to
do is evaluate two composite functions i
want to evaluate f of g of 0
and i want to evaluate g of f of zero so
like always pause the video and see if
you can figure it out
well let's first think about f of g of g
zero
f of g
of zero what is this all about and
actually let me let me use multiple
colors here f of
g of
zero
well this means that we're going to
evaluate g at zero so we're going to
input zero into g let me do it in that
so we're going to input 0 into our
function g
and we're going to output
whatever we output is going to be g of 0
i'll write it right over here and then
we're going to input that into our
function f we're going to input that
into our function f and whatever our
output then is going to be f of g of 0 f
of
g of 0
f of
g
of zero i wrote these small here so we
have space for the actual values so
first let's just evaluate and if this if
you are now inspired pause the video
again and see if you can if you can
solve it although if you solved it the
first time you don't have to do that now
well what's g of 0
well when
we input x equals 0 we get g of 0
is equal to 5.
so g of 0 is 5. so that is 5. so we're
now going to input 5 into our function f
we're essentially going to evaluate f of
5.
so when you input 5 into our function
and do it in this brown color when you
input x equals 5 into f you get the
function f of or you get f of 5 is equal
to 11.
so this is going to be 11. so f of g of
0 is equal to 11.
now let's do g of f of 0.
so now let's evaluate i'll do this in
different colors
g
maybe i'll use those same two colors
actually so now we're going to evaluate
g of
f of zero
g of f of zero and the the key
realization is you to go within the
parentheses evaluate that first so then
you can evaluate the function that's
kind of on the on the outside so here
we're going to take 0 as an input into
the function f
and then whatever that is that f of 0
we're going to input into our function g
and what we're going to be and then the
output of that is going to be g of f of
0.
so let's see what is f of 0 well you see
over here when you take
when our input is 0 this table tells us
that f of 0
is equal to 1.
so f of 0 is equal to 1
f of 0 is equal to 1. so now we use 1 as
an input into g we're now evaluating g
of 1.
so i can just write this this is the
same thing
as
g
of 1
g of 1. once again why was that because
f of 0 is equal to f of 0 is equal to 1.
and let me i wrote this parenthesis too
far away from the g
this is the same thing as
g of
because once again f 0 is 1. now what is
g of 1 well when i input
when i input 1 into our function g
i
get
g of 1 is equal to 8.
so this is going to be equal this is
equal to 8 and we're done and notice
these are different values because these
are different composite functions f of g
of 0 is 11 and g of f of 0 is 8.